hello and welcome to this mobile
marketing overview
my name is jeff hassan and by way of
introduction i got into mobile by
accident and it was the best thing
that's ever happened to my career
i'm currently the chief marketing
officer for a marketing company called
mobivity
and i was fortunate enough to be asked
to write a book on mobile marketing
called mobilize marketing how to drive
sales engagement and loyalty through
mobile devices
so let's talk about what mobile
marketing is
the mobile marketing association
identifies
mobile marketing as this it's a set of
practices that enables organizations to
communicate and engage with their
audience in an interactive and relevant
manner through any mobile device or
network
i have a friend who is the marketing
director at clear channel los angeles
and she works at one of the largest
radio stations in the world kiss fm
where ryan seacrest does his broadcasts
in the morning and what she said many
years ago and it's really an astute
comment she said why wouldn't i
communicate with my listeners the way
they communicate with each other
and she is a very active user of text
messaging because it's now become
ubiquitous
but really what we're talking about with
mobile marketing what we want to do is
have a dialogue or present the most
relevant and personal content that a
mobile user wants so they will respond
or react to our calls to action and they
will have this
roi driven relationship with us or maybe
we want to engage with them to to get
more brand equity and brand affinity
where does mobile fit in the marketing
mix
we fought for a seat at the table but i
believe
we have finally arrived where we can
show the roi we can talk about how
mobile can't be on an island and really
you should view it as it being
complementary to your other digital
efforts
in the majority of cases we're not
replacing everything in the marketing
mix what we're doing is we're making our
dollars work harder and become more
measurable by adding a mobile element
and this could be a radio spot where at
the end you have a call to action that
says for a two for one coffee drink text
the word bean to a short code
and then the person who did would get a
text message back would walk into the
coffee bean location would show that
message and would have the opportunity
to get there two for one and then in
many brands or businesses cases the
window is open or the opportunity is
open for you to have an ongoing
relationship and you might send a second
message that says would you like similar
information and offers
text the word join to a short code and
you're in the coffee bean loyalty club
now mobile also invigorates traditional
media
and it's always laughable when i read
where television is dying and radio is
going out the door and the current stats
show that this is entirely not the case
sure you might say that the glory days
of traditional media and might be behind
us but there really is an opportunity as
i've mentioned to make
what used to be passive
interactive that is
having somebody watch television and
asking them to participate in a contest
or text to win or uh actually what we
hope that they would do is maybe even go
and purchase product that they might see
and be intrigued by
and
most importantly the reason why mobile
fits into the marketing mix is it not
only
follows your target but it follows the
money because that's where more and more
commerce is being done more and more